[Music]
North Korea the land of crazy people hey
you shut your mouth and it seems as of
late the land of a very emboldened
people the little marionette looking
fellows of North Korea's administration
seem to be stepping up the plate quite a
bit in the past few months does anybody
else remember how nicely they played
from 2006 through oh nine hey Cheney
baby no no calm down
we just we pray we pray big joke ya know
ha ha we bought bomb we kill you ha ha
ha ha yeah everybody have big red for
cryin out loud they even publicly
destroyed one of their nuclear reactors
in the summer of o8 ya know we shut it
down right hey hey grace grace just said
shut down the nuclear reactor that one
yet no no I already have a week on to it
hey grace yeah
now we shutting it down right now yeah
gray yet all of a sudden in the past two
months they've launched how many
missiles I don't know I stopped counting
after the first couple but what could
have possibly changed you have
emboldened these people so hey Obama
yeah nice to hear your voice yeah much
more soothing than that though redneck
humility ha ha ha ha ha I make a funny
yeah yeah no we keep while we keep doing
the missile test you know yeah amidst
all of this
our president actually wants to shut
down our missile defense I can't believe
I actually just spoke those words out
loud listen this isn't some discussion
with your wife or your girlfriend where
you expose yourself for the betterment
of the relationship if this happens
millions of American lives will be at
stake share Obama's love the world round
but what good is that if tyrants don't
even respect you Hey President Obama
yeah hey do you have Prince Albert in a
can
oh yeah okay yeah what can you better
write about everybody read everybody
read I mean I guess it's it's not like
they're really a direct threat
they've only launched missile after
missile and formally stated that they
will wipe out the United States
I'm sure Lil Kim's actually a nice guy
did they care yes
[Music]
keep the change you filthy animal I run
a roll ha ha ha ha I mean how dangerous
could they be back my dear ajahn wrong
time yeah yeah no I have good stuff are
you very powerful yeah I said to you go
frats uh-huh yeah well you by now if I
throw ins free steamroller no no no no
no no steamroller
you know you do this yes steamroller
yeah ha ha ha how the protests are doing
oh yeah oh that's why you killed it oh
man you a character you know people ask
me hey have you at my dinner dad I say
man he want character you know what
about you do you think something serious
needs to be done about North Korea or
shall we just continue to bear witness
let me know oh and before you go he's
really sick and somebody else is just
gonna take his place soon have you seen
his possible successor that's my buddy
put me on the flow recipe
bring me some more that's my daughter
may God have mercy on us all
[Music]